fois tu as joué à touche-pipi dis le à
thierry jean louis aubert bonsoir alors
je me dis donc j'y pense parce que si tu
le dis toi c'est moins bien
as tu fait l'olympia le 18 mai ouais
voilà ce qui est dit est dit on va faire
le bilan de bleu blanc vert la halle
occitane avant de dormir d'abord aller
voilà des mois que tu sais on ne sait
pas ouais ça va moins bien pour ce soir
deux cent mille deux cent mille j'en
hachadi le ça tu peux le dire non je
crois que c'est ça mais je sais pas je
suis pas sûr je prends toujours les bons
chiffres mais c'est pas fini prêt
c'est un double album dont doublé durée
alors l'accueil critique tu penses quoi
de l'art aux critiques en france
c'est parce que ce qui se passe c'est
que l'alim one avant que les coupes mois
les peuples quand j'étais petit je
connais beaucoup de photos sont des murs
j'ai pas tellement d'articles on peut
coller à hollywood qui veut dire non je
trouve que les gens parlent ils ont pâte
énormément de plume toujours et elle ni
de coeur pour la forme
il manque un peu de compassion charrie
comme une maladie ça ne touche moins
qu'avant après le premier morceau de la
face à du 33 tours puissant le deuxième
morceau de la face à duran poitou de
poitiers tu vas tous et sans tirer le
maximum
ouais comme comme l'album menace est
assez grosse panne est pour une grande
part à illuminer à votre offre un squat
le troisième ça sera le troisième
morceau n'a pas de problème et je sais
pas comment choisir sa caisse café pour
la journée de la terre dimanche dernier
doit-il faire l'album bleu blanc vert
je suis sûr que comme on est dans une
société un peu plus tôt krassine société
de consommation que ça passera par les
individus par les consommateurs puisque
on les appelle comme ça ferait une
chance cette histoire de la terre pour
vraiment que cela les tours et les gens
vont arrêter de rouler en voiture pour
qu'en l'an 2000
la terre soit propre franchement je
pense qu'on peut avoir confiance dans le
futur sais pas s'ils vont arrêter de
rouler en voiture parce que lorsqu'on
leur dit d'arrêter de rouler en voiture
ils vont être arrêté de rouler un peu
parce que ils travailleront sur leur
contenu 13e et qu' ils n'auront pas
aller au boulot ils n'auront qu'à y
aller deux fois par semaine mais qui
sont en relation avec le monde entier
je crois qu'en fait la la communication
va peut-être résoudre beaucoup les
problèmes de déplacements qui sont quand
même des gros pollueurs qui laisseront
plus couler l'eau quand tu savais dans
quoi c'est pas ça qui va changer la
terre si tu veux c'est moi c'est congé
un lavabo il ya pas trop au fond et donc
je revenais à sortir et tu fait pivoter
c'est un vieux truc et donc ça m'arrive
16e arrangerait cendre noire s'était
levé romas aimerait bien qu'il ya une
espèce démission comme aux états unis où
on désigne des produits quand on sait ce
que là par exemple pour penser journée
j'utilise des petites piles au plomb la
sépaq non bah oui mais je ne sais même
pas on n'a jamais dit de les ramener les
mais quand je les ramène il disait jean
foot de les revendre à moi je trouve que
à des sourds franchement si si on trouve
pas de solution pour ces trucs pas il
faut carrément ne les jetez pas les
acheter la corsa
bon j'ai posé une question trombe comme
ça coûte vraiment besoin dit la posture
plus encore est-ce que tu commences par
les paroles s commence par les deux on a
une très belle voix les paroles d'un
côté la musique de l'autre et ça se rend
compte ou pas bon ces prélats moi faire
l'interview première fois
mon premier souvenir piquer des truffes
au chocolat dans un placard jouer du
piano dans un grand salon être enfermé
dans une cabane avec une grosse araignée
qui m'arrive de su monter à cheval sur
un canevas plat pour un psychanalyste et
pour la paix aujourd'hui comme une fois
tu arrives et le problème
j'ai pas les odeurs et tracy a tracé la
fenêtre regarder dans l'arrière de la
cuisse ou non tu as dans l'ain ton
premier péché c'est sûrement même temps
mais la fenêtre les truies forecasting
encore itunes bonne plutôt que ton père
était saoul précédent ouais c'est plein
de matches que vous ne souhaitez pas
vraiment pauvre court court terme est
vrai mais ça veut dire la une qui
maquille mais qui s'appelait mignonne
qui était assez charmante derrière et à
la demande venait dans les bureaux elle
me montre son derrière ça ne s'était pas
moi qui pêchaient et elle sort bien ton
premier fleurs oui en provence fonds
propres assis sur des troncs d'arbres
puis a franchi monté sur le trône d'un
conte a mis une après midi à s'embrasser
c'est très très difficile qui mettait la
langue je me suis renseigné auprès de
mon beau-frère papa le premier jour mais
le deuxième j'étais dire que
j'avais un nouveau truc ta première
fuite c'était sur le
c'est sur le bateau remonte angleterre
vous plaît s'écrouler les malades
ouais voilà une bouteille de whisky à
deux taxes la première fuite
moi j'ai jamais été jamais eu de
l'argent comptant et la gare
j'ai payé mes pas compact pour la même
quand avait 15 ans et j'aime l'idée
mais maintenant parce que je suis sûr
que non je réfléchissais en avant
première aventure chez lui avec un autre
garçon cette époque la guerre des
boutons les à la guerre des boutons ça
m'excitait beaucoup quand ils attachent
l'opticien juste et ouais j'avais un
copain là dedans en 8e 7e enfin en
général presque qui mes amis un stage là
ça finissait toujours dans des dykes à
gilly ou sous la halle sous les tables
et france en protégé par une table à
leur coeur et maintenant
maintenant c'est à dire et à lille en
gaieté qui était pas [ __ ] mais qui met
bien séduire les homos ça reste
platonique aurait cessé
je suis jamais très maître à bord les
avenues
mais là aussi c'est une acquisition
difficulté est clair mais par contre ça
nous arrive d'y penser en tournée
particulièrement son premier voyage son
soutien à l'étranger angleterre voir
l'angleterre l'angleterre il ya eu il ya
eu plusieurs jeunes chaque avec lui on
faisait la manche dans le métro à
longueuil guitare rouge du tarbouch on a
toujours notre jeu
là
je me suis un grand voyage c'était avec
olive on a traversé les états unis en
stop là je suis resté six mois nouvelles
de mes parents je reviendrai cadillac je
serai riche parce que ici la musique on
n'y comprend rien les mots de passe là
bas à la californie alors on est arrivé
à new york où il y avait louis à nouveau
et singer c'était très compliqué on a
mis une pancarte avec marc est ouest
dessus première banalisons par aegon est
un truc on est partis planor quatre mois
comme ça puis après je jouais dans un
groupe à los angeles et je suis revenu
avec moi je savais ce que j'avais à la
france tombe à point il était rappelé je
suis prêt mais j'aimais bien la poésie
me wade aime bien toujours réfugié très
vigilants regarde bien ce que je fais et
il me voit aussi beaucoup d'articles de
journaux ont fait un peu la collecte
d'informations qui pensent qu'il
pourrait me servir quelques face comme
certes pas quelquefois ça me sert
souvent je pense que je porte toujours
un truc de génération en génération
parce que je préside
peut-être qu'il a mis sous couverture la
cour la guerre la paix sociale etc
ton premier pétard plus qu'en 2d ouais
c'était quand
dans ma piaule de bonnes je devais
réviser le bac est un copain ou d'yves
le bon peuple
et voilà et c'était dur
ducasse du bazar midi et larry charles
c'était complètement dingue les gens n'y
croient pas et quel chanteur du groupe à
cette époque on avait l'impression
d'être dépuceler d'une certaine manière
et en fait c'était vraiment d'une
certaine m
tout est relatif d'un premier vote
c'était par an j'avais amené à la manif
du général de gaulle ray le 30 mai 68
nom julien clerc aussi je n'y a pas de
vente à un fonds qui avec vos parents
oui toi c'est pas moi souviens que je me
souviens qu'à la gars qui est passé avec
les et j'aurai un peu maigre et tout le
monde disait voilà me vouent une voile
amigou droite a fait dresser bimini de
woods et la livre ou non plus mais je
n'ai plus voter alors n'ont jamais
peut-être même même temps les écolos
notre bonne pour le chef de classe à
l'école je crois que les échos l'autre
votre apport non histoire je suis pas
écolo moi j'aime bien la terre j'aime la
nature je réfléchi à tout ça
cherchez pas trop être écolo